uh now some breaking news for you this
morning and roger hutton has announced
his resignation as chairman of the
yorkshire county cricket club it's all
in the wake of the azim rafiq racism
allegations
jackie's standing by in the glass box
what's going on jackie
well i don't think this is really a
surprise i mean what else uh could this
man do just disgraceful situation at
yorkshire widespread condemnation across
the world of sport not just cricket
after the azim
rafiq affair this is a player that
brought
many allegations of racism against the
club institutional racism at yorkshire
county cricket club and there was an
investigation by the club and seven
allegations were upheld and yet they did
nothing it was dismissed as friendly
good-natured banter no
action was taken whatsoever
yesterday the ecb did take action they
suspended international matches at
headingley
so there will be no test match there
next year or one day international
sponsors
made their feelings known as well nike
terminated their deal uh with the
uh club as did several other sponsors um
he said this morning that the club
should have recognized at the time the
serious allegations
of racism he's apologized unreservedly
to 30-year-old rafiq
and he was also very critical of the
england and wales cricket board saying
that the governing body didn't help them
there is an emergency board meeting at
yorkshire today more resignations are
expected
and hunton says some non-executive board
members have already left their post um
the investigation did find that rafiq
was a victim of racial harassment and
bullying
but the club said they would no take no
disciplinary action well action is
definitely happening now
there is going to be a hearing by the
culture media and sports select
committee into this on november the 16th
and
the first man has already fallen on his
sword this morning roger hutton the
chairman of yorkshire county cricket
club has resigned in the last few
minutes